[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled human induced plur potent
stem cell expansion in a stirred 3D
system an example of manufacturing
allogenic resources for cell therapy
this webinar is a part of the fifth
annual event in the bioprocessing
virtual event
series I am Shelley muok of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
dasgip and endorf Company for more
information about dasgip and endorf
Company Go to endorf dcom e p p n d o RF
now let's get
started before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our live chat feature
during the presentation you can find the
live chat located at the left of your
screen you can also participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
in the ask a question box and click
submit we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located at the top of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the
lobby finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and following follow
the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker Dr
Jorge Escobar is a senior research
scientist in the applications lab of
endorf Incorporated for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the presenter presenter tab from the
menu at the top at the left of your
screen Dr Escobar you may now begin your
presentation thank you for this kind
introduction um it's a great pleasure
for me today to talk to the to the
audience and explain uh the platform we
have developed for human induced pood
and stem cells and uh expansion in in a
stereo 3D system as a perfect example
for allogeneic uh Cell Therapy
applications
so Ender is a leading uh life science
company founded in in Hamburg Germany in
in 1945 with the purpose of improving uh
human living conditions so our company
have subsidiaries in over 26 uh
countries uh developing and providing
solution for uh to our customers with
the mission to bring life saving
treatments uh to the
war so the application Labs located in
nfield Connecticut and and ulish in
Germany along with the with the openend
door application technology lab located
in namur in Belgium develop bioprocess
solution for our customers uh in selling
gene therapy uh proteins and vaccine
production in uh
let me see so in this regard our
colleagues or our researchers have
developed over the years uh an extensive
library of application notes with a
specific details about you know uh
vaccines and protein Productions and
celling gene therapy workflow like the
one I'm planning to present to you
today so going more into details uh let
me talk a little bit more about uh about
the advanc therapy so advaned therapy
medicinal products uh
atmp are innovated uh biopharmaceutical
for for human use where the aptis
substance is the the biological uh
substance or is Harvest from a
biological source so as you see in the
slide um us and and and EUR have uh
different regulation but they have a
similar subclassification like like gene
therapy and and cell therapy and in the
case of europeo they have two Moro
classification as um dies engineered
products and also the combination of
atmp product that could be for example a
medical device like cells embed in in a
matrix or a scaffold for uh tisue
regeneration by looking at the
complexity and side uh you can see that
advanc therapies are much more complex
than the biologics or small molecules uh
which means the atmp are highte products
develop on the very specific complicated
process that are at the Forefront of
innovation with more more chances of
finding cure for patients so the aim
between the small molecules and the
advanced therapy is quite different I
have to say that and uh it is not to
have a pharmacological effect in the
body the idea is uh basically to
introduce cells or tissue in the human
body even in the side of the defect of
the disease the disease or remove from
there in order to replace or restore uh
loss functions or even introduce genetic
material into the cells or tissue to
compensate for its uh
absence
um so it's important to highlight here
that this is a revolutionary technology
where the cells are living drugs and
with the ability to respond to the micro
environment in the very personalized
way so talking more uh specifically
about cell engine therapy cgt this is an
important part of the of the
atmp and they are a transformative new
category of
medicines uh and their full potential is
just beginning to to start so singing
therapies involve extracting cells as
you see in the slide proteins or genetic
material from the patient or a donor and
Engineering them to provide a highly
personalized Med therapy where the the
the cell or this genetic information is
re inject or reinus into into the
patient in addition uh to that I would
like to say that they have the potential
to address a complex diseases and rare
disorder for which uh there is no
effective cure uh
yet talking a little bit about the
market um you see that the global sell
engine therapy Market is set to grow
close to10 billion from 2022 to
2026 according to techn view and um the
market grow momentum will accelerate
with the grow around
20% with the cell therapy segment uh
being the largest contributor to the
market and North America accounting for
41% of the markets over the forecast
period so there are different type of
celline therapy approaches and uh Auto
is is one of them and I have to say that
this is an really an example of a
personalized medicine so cells are
exract from the patient and Infuse again
into the same patient uh patient after a
laborious procedure of cell isolation
expansion and
validation so as order aut Cell Therapy
uh strategy present present key features
and and Challenge and um for example the
cell therapy has very low immunogenicity
that means that the cells are from the
same patient and they have demonstrate
strong efficacy in different clinical
trials however it present the strategy
present also several uh challenge for
example Manufacturing and that can take
um two to three weeks to make a
therapeutic dose while patients May
progress um waiting for the treatment
the cost is is high also and
um and is uh lots are personalized and
and Manufacturing process are difficult
uh to scale up effectively and finally
as you see in the slide they have poor
reliability uh um uh meaning that if
something goes wrong um you know during
the manufacturing the patient will not
receive the therapy on
time uh regarding to that I mean this
Challenge rais questions about whether
an alternative approach can be
considered taken into consideration of
this all this knowledge accumulated uh
with the current autologous strategy and
offer a more simple solution to develop
a Cell Therapy product for for many
patients so this is a case of the
allogenic uh approach where cells uh
from a healthy donor and are you know
collect expand are and use for many
patients from the manufacturing point of
view the goal is to develop a scale of
model capable to produce
affordable bashes for a 100 patients and
this is I want to say that this is
really truly offthe shell uh
product so I I want to show here a clear
example of allogene strategy
specifically um um analogic Cel therapy
approach I do want to go more really
into detail here but as you can see in
the slide there are different steps in
the off string such as tell uh cell T
Cell isolation the prosure the T Cell
characterization and banking going into
the the scale of process uh and in in
that step you can expand the cells you
can activate the T cells and you can
transduct and then you can have C
expression and you can have all these
using for example a Solutions and uh
those are the the solutions and
controller that uh that that we have and
we can provide
so in this case treatments can be made
in advance and will be available as soon
as the patient is referred for treatment
and this is very convenient in case of
uh in cases where it is necessary to
administer multiple doses because
patient no longer respond to the initial
uh treatment also uh because this is uh
off the shell treatment there is a
minimal risk of manufacturing failures
and finally I want to say that allogen a
product can be manufactured in batches
allowing for more efficient scale of
processes uh for these reasons uh there
there is a significant shift toward
allogen therapy development as you see
in the slide we see a shift coming a big
shift coming from Auto cell and gene
therapy to allogenic uh cell and and
gene therapy strategy so according to
the global uh Market estimate the
allogen a Cel therapy Market is expected
to grow at the annual growth rate of
99.6% from 2022 to
2027 where the L larg segment will be
stem cells and also cancer
therapies also so um uh a crb group
serving more than 500 leaders in the
lify industry and they found that the
developer from largers smaller and and
even cdmo organizations are moving away
from the small patient specific budget
and to allogeneic uh
processes uh theological rejection is
one of of the principal disadvantages of
of this therapy so I want to explain a
little bit more here so the the host
immune system attack the implant cells
causing um side reactions to the patient
or they can cause between mild to severe
side effect to the patients so I don't
want to go into detail here but there is
a certain gene therapy there are certain
gene therapy strategies to prevent graph
versus H disease the idea is to have is
is is to have or to use a universal
allogenic cell source for different
biomedical application and I have to say
that this uh one step closer uh to
reality in this sense induced proot stem
cells and everybody knows that ipsc are
the right from somatic cells and they
have been reprogrammed back into the
embryonic life report
state that allow for the development of
any human cell type needed for uh
therapeutic uh
purposes yeah to deliver of the shell an
inexpensive ipsc dry products uh to more
patients is necessary to generate a
universal
ipsc uh that can be transplanted regard
of the um the human lecoy antigen
HLA allotypes I will explain a little
bit more what what that means and and
and what is important so hlaa our cell
surface uh proteins and if the T cells
of the transplant cells uh and the immun
host system and they do not recognize
each other because they don't have they
don't match the
hlaa uh there is an immune response and
then the tissue is rejected
yeah most of the strategy of editing
consists in two different steps and I
will explain them here so first of all
the complete sepration of HLA to avoid
imun reaction and then uh we need to
Spread spread certain molecules in the
in the in the cells that we are
implanting in order to avoid natural
kill cells attack so let me go in into
detail here let me explain more into
details what what is going on as you see
in this slide in order to delete HLA
expression uh both hla1 and hla2 must be
deleted and um but because of these
regions uh you know is they are very
large is very difficult to delete that
uh by Gene editing so the easy way to
suppress that is uh by suppressing uh by
deleting
b2m uh which is the common subunit of
hla1 so as you see in the slide so if
you want to delete H1 and avoid this
CS attack so we will delete the
b2m uh portion and then uh by doing that
you will delete completed the H one and
class one then we'll do the same with
the H uh class two by deleting s uh Cit
D Gene and and which is a transion
factor essential for H2
expression and um and then we can
suppress the H2 by doing that the point
is that if we lost H class one which is
a Lian for natural killer inhibitor
receptor will that situation will C
cause that the the natural kill cells
attack the the new allogenic ipsc cell
El in order to avoid that and escape
from that but from that situation uh we
have to force on expression of different
inhibitor lians like H and hlae as you
see here in the
slide this is a very complicated process
but uh I see some papers that people uh
in the field working on
that so currently there are many
clinical trials uh involv in allogenic
ipsc Drive uh uh cell therapy for
example the ipsc drive enk cells to
treat solid solid and and un liquid
tumor also allogenic
ipsc um uh derve cardom myoides in the
treatment in patient with ischemic heart
failure uh also ipsc Drive mesena stens
cils for the treatment of steroid
resistant acute uh graph versus host
diseases and finally ipsc dry card enk
cells to treat subjects with multiple
meom so the manufacturing process of the
ipsc nowadays including you know the
preculture and and reprogramming is a
labor intenses intensive and open
process
procedure which need a lot of daily uh
manipulation in including medium
refreshment and that can cause and this
is a high uh risk you know this is a
situation with high risk of
contamination and we should avoid that
so and also the scalability is very
important for the allogenic allogen Cell
Therapy development but it can be
difficult to aeve achieve the goal is to
build a control manufacturer process
that reliably can produce the cell year
and quality generate in the early
development stages for clinical trials
and Commercial and Commercial scale in
this sense starting materials undergo an
expansion process and then they are
transferred into large scale platform uh
such as bioreactors we can be used uh
subsequentially to generate cell
quantity required for allogeneic cell
therapy so we need to produce a lot of
cells to you know to be able to uh use
them for for many biomedical uh
applications so in this sense it's
important to track the ipsc morphology
and also the aggregate side because you
don't want them to get and to grow
really big because you can get necrotic
areas in the core of these Aggregates
and you can can lost the cells and also
because the ipsc have a lot of
spontaneous differentiation and you
don't want that situation that situation
happen also uh the final dissociation uh
process of the ipsc aggregate is a
challenge um because it may change the
cell
characteristic uh impacting directly in
the in the IPS
production
so we have an extense collaboration with
Professor Roberts berer lab from Hanover
Medical School and uh during that
collaboration we have developed a new
steering impeller design that support
more homogeneous ipsc aggregate
formation and also we have developed a
retention a retention device that is a
kind of filter device that allows
keeping the aggregate of ipsc in this
serious suspension C allowing a
continuous perfusion feed feeding so
without stopping the agitation without
stopping the gasing we can continuously
add medium and refresh medium and and
into into the system um professor as
laboratory
hasum you know extensive knowledge over
the years with more than 50 Publications
in the last three years alone as you see
in the
slide so son of this publication
describe various optimization studies
including agitation speed pH do control
glucose
supplementation different feeding
strategy how the impeller geometry
affects the ipsc proliferation and the
aggregate information using specifically
the Dax boox mini bioreactor system
develop by our company I want to
highlight here that they have obtained
30 million viable cells per milliliter
uh in a 150 150 Mill working volume
using this ablade uh impeller
configuration in per
Fusion so now I'm going to introduce
some details about what uh we have
developed and and the example that we
develop uh in the bioreactor based uh
human iPic aggregate production on a
suspension start cure platform using one
liter bioreactor control by cyber twin
bioreactor control system so basically
as you seen the slide how we were able
to create the colonies in 2D and by
using cber twin uh bi reactor consol
system how we were were able to obtain
the human ipsc aggregate in in
3 so let me first introduce the siberio
so the cber twi Biore reactor control
system is our new controller it is
capable of controller of controlling two
single use of glass bioreactor either
individual or individually or in
parallel and using a wide range of
bioreactor size with a working volume uh
from 1.3 to 40 lit even though for
microbial or uh for cell cure
configuration so we have performed two
median exchange back bash culture uh of
course using Siberia uh and twin and
then we did that simultaneously using
dasy vessels with a working volume of
0.8 lit and AIP with a blade impeller
optimized for human indu p important
stem cells
expansion so let me explain in details
the the ipsc expans workflow used in
this work as as you see in in this slide
so the first step where the ipsc
precursor um The Colony peing process to
avoid impurities followed by IPS
characterization and to the expansion so
let me go and explain um you know the
process step by
step so the payment were performed using
uh a human ipsc cell line drive for from
dermal fi fiolas obtained from a healthy
donor and we we obtain that cell line
from
atcc so the I as you see in the slide
the ipsc where SE in the vit connecting
code six wheel play using the proor stem
Flex medium from therof Fisher also
supplement uh with rabit cell also
obtained from from thermop Fisher at the
density of four 10 to the^ of four cell
per square cm as you see in the
slide um the medium was changed daily
and at day five you see a well defined
uh colonies and this six will PL
containing all this ipsc Colony uh was
removed from the cell expert C 170i
incubator and you see you have one of
the you know the picture in this slide
and place uh the the six wheel play in
the laminina hood under the
microscope um for Colony pecking so we
did that but you know if you see um the
morphology of of the of the colony in
this slide you see that there are like
kind of they have a circular morphology
so um we we like trace a circle around
the colony border with a needle and by
using a p200
pipet um we remove the IPC colony from
the surface of the
plate uh this Colony ping
um
process uh has continued until enough
ipsc cell have been collect and then the
ipsc cells were SE in a vitting t75 FL
and incubated at 37 celsus with CO2 uh
percent of uh 5% of CO2 in in the same
in incubator so we we have changed uh
the medium the day after seating and
then every day every other day until the
C reach the Desir confluency and we have
continued this to the expansion process
as sh in this slide until we obtain more
than 800 million cells that there were
the you know the amount sufficient to
prepare a dayum for both
bioreactors then the next step was the
ipsc characterization through the ipsc
plural potency expression so we have
used flow citometry and also we have use
immunocyto cytochemistry so let's
explain a little bit so the single cells
that we collect from the T the T FL were
incubated with con conjugate antibodies
against TR 160 against
SSA four and one and also with the
correspondent
isotypes and um at at 30 for 30 minutes
at four Celsius degrees degrees so
sample uh after that the sample were
required using a wava flow cytometer and
analyze it by fluu uh software as you
see in figure a uh we show positive
expression of this potency
markets um and uh and also this
fluesy um was confirmed by the imuno
cyto chemetry staining using o4 and TR
160 that you see
inferior so after obtaining the amount
of cells to prepare the inoculum uh for
both bioreactors The Next Step was the
inoculation process and the ipacc
expansion in in
suspension so before running any kind of
experiment so here specifically in
bioprocess we have three important
components uh to consider first of all
the bioreactor the controller and then
finally the inog glue so let me explain
uh all of them in detail first of all I
would like to explain the bioreactor so
how we set up the bioreactor the day
before the ination we perform first of
all the PA sensor calibration by
connecting the PA sensors to the cyberia
T by reactor control system and then we
perform this calibration according to uh
the operation manual so then each d one
lit glass vessel was assembled with the
ph and the sensors also we have include
two di tubes along with the compression
proof pro adapter insert in a spare
pg13.5 Port so one for inoculation
median exchange and this and and the
second one for
inoculation and and median addition
sorry and also uh we have uh include two
addition ports in each vessel head PL
one for base addition in this case we
use sodium
bicarbonate and um the second one for
the addition of uh antio that in this
case we use pluronic f 6A sulur tank so
after we assembled the Biore reactor we
sterilize them and we put them so we
place them again back into their
respective temperature control block to
keep the system at Conant temperature so
then we have connected drives and also
we have connect the Peltier exhaust
condenser and and also the this paral
line coming from the controller directly
into the sumerge spash filters on the
The Vessel so once the the you know the
reactors were settled and put it in the
in the hidden block uh we had finally
the 600 M of uh scale medium
supplemented with 0.1% of pluronic and
then 10 micromolar of Y
27632 ragent and condition for at least
24 hours uh using the parameters and sub
points that are list here in in this
table finally after 24 hours of
conditioning we inoculate the DUS 1
liter uh glass vessel with 200 mL of uh
medium containing 400 million cells and
and with the density around 0.4 10 to
the six 10 to the^ six cell per
milliliter with
97% of cell VI viability so after that
the inoculation happened so we wait like
half an hour and we took sample from
both bi reactors and uh we did that Al
also Daily and we measure also the ph
and and and metabolize uh every
day um so we did the the the measure of
cell density and viability using a v
cell analyzer and also the the
metabolite concentration was obtained
using a c
bioanalyzer so once we we sample from
the bio reactor we have the ipsc
Aggregates and we have also the the C
Cal medium so how we did that we
wait between two and five minutes in
order for the ipac aggregate to sett
down in the bottle of of the of our bile
and we took the supern so means the
medium to measure the metabolites and
then um on the other hand we use the
Aggregates of uh to to to measure uh the
cell viability and cell density but of
course we first of all we have to
dissociate the cell pellet and uh in
order to do that we we use a gentle
salce dissociation region from stem cell
technology so we had that for five
minutes at 37 celsus degrees and G
gentle P pipet up and down and we were
able to uh uh dissociate the p and the
single single
sauce then as I explained before that
was a meeting exchange uh performance
and we did that daily after 24 hours
from the Single Cell inoculation until
day five so how we did that so we
stopped the agitation and gas flow uh
for five minute for five minute allowing
again the ipsc aggregate to sett them
down in the bottle of our our bioa ctor
and then
using an uh using a deep tube we remove
40% of the of the of our cell Cal medium
from the top uh without disturbing the
the ipsc Aggregates and then using one
of the liquid addition Port that we have
built in the in the head in the head
plate uh using that we were able to
include or add that again 40% needed
with fresh with fresh medium without any
supplementation so as you see in the
slide we we observe an an initial lag uh
phase meaning that the cell viability
decrease uh in day one and and we have
seen this in in in similar studies but
uh as you see that follow a rough happen
increase in both bio reactor between day
two and day five of culture creasing
peak in viable s density of um of around
8 million cells per milliter with um a
susequent subsequent decrease in cell
density and and viability as a Spector I
want to highlight here that the cell
density uh was higher than 90% up to day
uh until day five and also it's
important to highlight that you know the
higher producibility obtained in this
run from both bioreactor using our our
controller and furthermore we determine
the consumption of glucose and the
production of late and ammonia as you
see in
FB while at the same time we maintain
the concentration of this metabolite
below um uh 2 G per liter and 2 m moo
per liter
respectively during the the whole
run so the downstream process of the
ipsc expansion workflow includes the
aggregate Harvest and and control test
and uh so we wanted to demonstrate that
large scale expansion uh process is
compatible with the ipsc ploty and
that's why we want to study the plur
poeny uh and you know during during the
process during the scale
process so first of all in order to
evaluate the growth kinetic and
morphology of the ipsc on specific
suspension culture conditions the the
sample were har Harvest uh after 24
hours and uh after 2 four hours of
inoculation and every day until day five
so how we did that so we collect samples
using a
laer uh B with a line set and is you
know thermop fish provide that and how
we did that we use that b and we weld
the back into uh to one of our uh our
liquid addition Port without
interrupting the gasing and the steering
so by doing that uh we were able to
collect our samples uh daily and then
using that sample by using that samples
uh we obtain 10 bright field images from
both
bioreactors uh with mean aage uh of
around uh 20 single cells aggregate
using uh images so we use like 20
Aggregates uh to to collect all these uh
uh pictures and also we have monitor the
the human ipsc Aggregates formation and
diameter as as you see in this
slide
so 24 hours for single cell inoculation
the IP the ipsc aggregate formation was
found with the average diameter
increasing for 90 95 microns uh in day
one as you see in the slide to 530
microns a day five I want to I want to
emphasize here that the ruler in the
picture are are equivalent to 400 micros
and um
we see like a totally narrow
distribution of aggregate diameter uh in
the first stage in the in the first day
but uh after inoculation but after that
we saw a broader aggregation diameter uh
distribution at the late uh stage as you
see in the
image and finally as I mentioned before
a large scale production of human
ipsc uh cells while maintaining the pr
potency is essential for clinical
application uh in this regard uh most of
the cell forming aggregate Harvest at
day four because we did that specific um
um assay uh on day four so and we
Harvest this aggregate from both
bioreactors and I want to highlight here
that the aggregate side was around 400
migr in diameter at that day so all the
sample all these cells Express PR poent
associate uh Associated to surface
markers like s sea4 and tri 160 and also
uh we saw uh positive PL potency uh in
immunocyto chemistry uh using
transcription factors as uh such as o4
and
Nano uh and similar uh to to the same
result we get when we have the human
ipsc in monol layers so I want to
highlight that these beautiful images
from our uh IPC Aggregates were obtained
uh using a k focal on
microscope so finally we would like to
announce our uh EST Cel Community Day
coming in November uh 21st in Leen in
Belgian with really invite all of you to
become a member of our community and
connect with Scientists from Academia
and and Industry to discuss the most
recently most recent advance and and and
new technologies in the stenc Cel uh
field and with that I would like to
thank you for your attentions and I will
be happy to take an equation you can
have thank you Dr Escobar for your
informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen let's get
started uh the first question is uh is
there another strategy to avoid
rejection of allogenic grafts by the
host's immune system after infusing ipsc
cells well we have discussed here one
strategy that is basically H uh H
editing ipsc cells but of course
currently there are uh some uh
strategies like immunosuppressive
treatments like by taking a medication
you can you know suppress your immune
immune system but but the point is that
that basically take like three to 12
months for your immune system to recover
from this transplant and
also also
I I I know another way uh so by creating
large ipac bank for a 100 donors uh that
can March actually all type so I
recently read um an article from CRA
Foundation uh from Kyoto University and
they have developed a clinical drade H
Al Bank uh with human uh ipsc cells and
then matching approximately 40% of the
Japanese population something that is
quite
impressive ah well thank you for that um
the next question is did you perform a
kype analysis of the
ipscs that are part of the Aggregates oh
that's a pretty this is a good question
so as everybody knows carot type
analysis is essential to determine uh
any gen um genomic alteration in the
cells but I have to say that we haven't
performed that we don't have data but
this is an ongoing study right
now sure makes sense thank you um our
next question is you mentioned that you
used a one liter glass vessel fitted
with eight blade impellers have you
tried other impeller
geometry no we haven't try that we have
uh as you see I explained all these uh
um studies that uh Robert sper Professor
Robert sper have uh performed in his lab
and we kind of adap the best conditions
the best possible condition for us to
MIM or reproduce uh the
ipsc uh agregat formation in our
laboratory that's why we we use the
blade imped configuration
I see okay thank you um we have another
question which is how do you recommend
testing the quality of ipsc throughout
the reprogramming and expansion steps
well I have explained this in in the
presentation there are many ways so you
can you know for example you can uh
study the morphology uh the morphology
will change if something is wrong during
the you know your expansion also you can
use FL cytometry and Moc
cytochemistry um to determine the bluy
potency expression using for example
what I did
D60 o4 Nano Etc and um but you know and
also you can you can use kype analysis
to see if there is any uh genomic
alteration in in the
cells all right all right thank you for
that um have you ever tried any other
preculture expansion protocol other than
T flask expansion this is a really good
question so this is an Ono and stall it
right now so rather than using uh or or
trying to span the cells in Tod we are
right now trying to span the Sals in 3D
using the Aggregates uh in in ch FL and
I think that we can save time and we can
have more more cells uh and for the
inoculation process okay all right um
the next question is I see that you did
a medium supplementation can you explain
a little more in detail so basically we
didn't do any supplementation what we
did was a median exchange as I explained
before so we have we have include a de
tube that was halfway in in our bi
reactor and then uh because we need to
refresh to do medium refreshment at
certain period of time what we did what
what we stopped the agitation and
gassing because if you have the
agitation of course and ging and gasing
all these ipsc aggregate will be FL in
in in the medium so we want them to
settle down in the Bott of the of the of
the bioreactor and and and by doing that
we were able to remove the liquid from
the top and then by using one of the
addition ports that we had already uh
included in in the configuration
we were able to include that 40% of
fresh media that we uh previously took
out from the bioreactor this is the
configuration we use to do medium
refreshment in our in our uh workflow
yeah okay wonderful thank you Dr escavar
um we're going to wrap up with this
final question um how do you digest the
ipsc
Aggregates well also I mentioned that in
the presentation so so that's uh this is
pretty simple once you have the
Aggregates so you have to remove the
medium from the from that uh that sample
and then you will wash you know the the
ipsc aggregate with dpvs and then we we
tried different uh dissociation regions
but we found that uh the the gentle C
dissociation region from the stem cell
technology was uh the best one we we
mained a high viability using that and
then we did so we we maintain the the
you know the C on the uh with 500
microliter of this region for five
minutes under uh in in in the incubator
at at 37 Celsius degre degrees and after
that we did uh up and you know up and
down movement with one milliliter
serological pipet because using teeth
you can damage the cells and uh we found
that by doing that uh we obtained the
best results the the best possible
results all right excellent well thank
you again Dr Escobar for your time today
and your important research uh before we
go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions I'd also like to
thank our sponsors dasgip and endorf
Company for sponsoring today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted dur during the on
demand period will be addressed by the
speaker via a contact information you
provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand for two years until April 5th
2025 lab Roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye